was a double piece sacrificed by the
15th world champion playing very
aggressively and now Knight F5 on the
board attacking the black king but it's
very interesting what Anand has in mind
after Bishop E6
even he takes on G7 and the queen H6 but
Bishop G4 what what can you do what what
can you oh yeah
wow sacrificing a rook and a piece that
would be made on G7 what can you do with
black hair
well
yes Rook E6 seems to be a move Rook H4
is possible Bishop AJ oh wow
look at that cool move the lightest pin
the bishop is would be hanging but the
Rook is hanging everything is hanging
and it's made on G7 and now there is
nothing to be done beautiful it's game
over what a beautiful game by the 15th
world champion